the traffic ministration was given
advanced warning of Muller's plan to
make a public statement today after
watching the special council the White
House had a coordinated response it is
time to move on
correspondent Kevin cork has reaction
from the White House from the vice
president to the White House press
secretary from the Trump campaign to his
private attorneys a virtual Blizzard of
statements from inside and outside the
Trump White House about Bob Muller's
comments today each with a definitive
conclusion Jay Sekulow said it puts a
period on a two-year investigation Trump
campaign wrote that there was no case
for obstruction
even Vice President Mike Pence weighed
in the investigation is complete all
proclaiming an end to an investigation
that White House officials believe
should never have taken place to begin
with he said it was completed
he's case closed he's shutting down his
office and he's moving on and going back
to his private life and we think it's
great that he's doing that and we hope
everybody else does that as well a
cinnamon echoed by the president who
took to Twitter to proclaim his
innocence there was insufficient
evidence and therefore in our country a
person is innocent the case is closed
case closed perhaps from the president's
perspective but seemingly not to Muller
whose comments today led some of the
White House to wonder if he was merely
setting the stage for congressional
Democrats to begin an impeachment
drumbeat the president's lawyer Rudy
Giuliani a frequent critic of the Mahler
team was bemused when a prosecutor can't
reach a decision that's the decision so
there's no case on obstruction there's
no case on collusion I did it two years
I never have found a right anyone I
found if there are enough evidence to
bring a charge or isn't there evidence
bring a charge in this case red barring
a congressional subpoena Bob Muller has
made clear his preference not to testify
further on the rush of matter saying his
report are the final words he'd prefer
to have on that topic meanwhile no word
here at the White House on whether or
not the president will have more
comments about Muller's remarks today
Brett Kevin quark love the North Lawn
Kevin thanks